- [Narrator] Coastal at one moment,
isolated island at another,
Mont Saint-Michel is incredibly
stunning no matter the tide.
In between two powerful tides
from Normandy and Brittany
stands the gothic-styled
Benedictine Abbey named after
and dedicated to the
archangel Saint Michael.
Mont Saint-Michel wasn't always an island.
In prehistoric times,
it stood on dry land.
However, as sea levels rose,
erosion reshaped the coast.
Even today, it only sits
600 meters from land.
Although it has less than
50 full-time residents,
it is visited by more than
three million people each year.
The climb to see the abbey isn't easy.
It's around 900 steps.
More than just a church on a rock,
Mont Saint-Michel is a
medieval time capsule
and was one of the first
monuments to be classed
as a UNESCO World Heritage
Site back in 1979.